so this question comes from
travis roberts at nm underscore uap
i have seen some interviews broach the
dodie benowitz issue with linda but it
doesn't seem to go well
much of linda's information can be
traced back can be traced back to miss
to mr disinformation himself i just want
to know her relationship with him
you're talking about april 9th
1983
uh kirtland air force base in
albuquerque
this was a meeting set up for me by
peter gersten the attorney who
filed foia the first foia
freedom
freedom of information act requests
um
for citizens against ufo secrecy
and
his name was peter gersten
let's i'll go back to get to the
timeline
in
march
of
1983
i was in new york city at home box
office signing a contract with home box
office to produce an hour film for hbo
they already had the working title ufos
the e.t factor
i had the meeting that afternoon with
executives at hbo and the head of the
documentary unit
i had already provided them a script
outline of what i wanted to do in ufos
the e.t factor and everybody was
extremely excited about doing this film
that night
i knew peter gerson and patrick wage
peter gersten had represented citizens
against ufo secrecy in the very first
freedom of information act filings as an
attorney
that led up to a supreme court
session
in which
the he had he peter
had filed against all known
intel agencies
for information about ufos and what they
were and represented and it finally
there was a headline in january of 1980
about this and the fact that when in
an in-camera session took place
uh with peter gersten there as an
attorney representing citizens against
ufo secrecy
the only
thing that was allowed were pages all
blocked out
stanton friedman would use those
pages blacked out for years after in his
conferences that this is what the
government
said to peter gersten on freedom of
information act request about what do
you know about ufos and ets
so that is the person peter gerson that
i met with after my hbo contract signing
that night
and he and peter wage and i
uh sat around on a small table where
peter had a briefcase and he started
bringing out documents handwritten
letters
typed letters
of a person
richard c doughty
on the documents on the letters who
worked at kirtland air force base
in afosi air force office of special
investigations
peter gerson is showing me linda howe
the producer now with the new contract
for hbo
look at what he is saying in these
letters
and the letters were about the exchange
of a some kind of a laser what looked
like a laser beam
at ellsworth air force base
in which they had eyewitness military
that a silver disk landed
an opening came on the side
a security guard drew his weapon
an opening came in the ufo
a blonde being perhaps
came out
the
security guard
pulled the trigger
or was about to pull the trigger
and and what looked like a laser beam
hit the security guard's hand holding
the gun
his skin
was burned surface burned
but one of the amazing things to our
government was
what is that weapon because we want it
he dropped the gun but it did not
destroy the hand
with surface burns this is what peter
presented to me with at that dinner that
night in new york he said we want to
investigate this and that this afosi
agent in albuquerque new mexico
has information
and we want to set up a meeting
you go talk to him about the ellsworth
air force base we want to investigate as
citizens against ufo secrecy
and you can cover it as a segment in hbo
two weeks later
peter gerson calls
says here's the phone number
he says he can meet with you on april
9th
call and confirm
so when i flew down to albuquerque
to have the meeting it was set up by
peter gersten the attorney
what i was supposed to be given
information about i was told
is
the ellsworth case
when
i am taken into the afosi office through
all these punch locks where they have to
punch buttons to get through doors
and we went into
a big office he said my boss said to use
his office
and we go into this office and as we are
there were two stairs down from the door
to where the actual desks in the office
were
he said
you broadsided the united states
government with that film you did
and i
i'm thinking peter gersten and ellsworth
what are you talking about
he said your documentary is strange
harvest
we never thought
that any credible professional
journalist would touch that with a
100-foot pole
that's how that started
that's exactly where it started
and he sat down behind the desk and
motion to a chair
and
i think that i am there
to get the names of witnesses to the
laser shooting at ellsworth air force
base that peter gerson and i would work
on as a segment for hbo
and when i asked him if he had the
witness names because that's what peter
said to ask for
he said
that's really not as important as my
superior officers i think is the way he
put it or my superiors
have asked me to show you this and he
reached into a drawer and pulled out a
that kind of shape envelope
and reached in
and pulled out
maybe
12 pages
and he said
you can read this
but you cannot take notes
and i want you to move from the chair
you're in to that chair and there was a
large chair in the middle of this large
office
later on i would learn that that chair
was what was used to videotape people
who were brought to that office but
right then
everything is changing because i think i
am supposed to get the witness names
of ellsworth
and leave
i had another meeting scheduled with
other people in new mexico
but now i have in front of me on the top
page all caps
briefing paper for the president of the
united states of america on the subject
of unidentified aerial craft
the briefing paper did not use ufo uap
it was uac
and
unidentified area vehicles uavs uavs and
uacs
the first page
was the typical robinson panel sign
grudge
mantel the airplane that was exploded by
a ufo all
coming into the first page the second
page i'm reading history
and then somewhere around the third page
in the middle
it came down to
a subject
about in the past
in the ancient past
and it said
these extraterrestrial biological
entities manipulated dna in already
evolving primates to create homo sapien
and the latin homo sapien was there
and then it went on for two or three
more sentences
did it happen to give a timeline up
no
no
and then it went on for two or three
more sentences
and at the end of this document tying to
that paragraph
was a
list of project names
and the top project all caps
project garnet i made a note to myself
that
remember your birthstone linda remember
your birthstone i'm born january 20th
and the birthstone is garnet
so it said project garnet
all caps and this is exactly what it
said because i've never forgotten
all questions and mysteries
about the evolution of homo sapien on
this planet have been answered and this
project is closed
and i am a person
who i'm sitting there
because i thought i was doing a military
ellsworth
laser shootout
with a being at a silver disk
i'm being shown a briefing paper for the
president of the united states allegedly
that is talking about ancient history
and the manipulation of dna in already
evolving primates to create humans
and that it is referenced twice in the
papers
from that day
forward
because
as a professional when i got back to
denver the first person i called was
jean abinador the director of uh hbo
documentary in new york
i explained
i came for a meeting about ellsworth
i have now been presented a paper that
seems to imply that the entire evolution
of humanity is related to genetic
manipulation by extraterrestrial
biological entities
she said
you must come back to new york for
another meeting
we must talk about this with bridget
potter and michael fuchs was the head of
hbo and bridget potter potter was second
in command
and
two weeks later
i'm in new york
i'm sitting in front of bridget potter i
explain everything i've just explained
to you
i have some materials
and she said unless
you can bring to me statements or the
person who is president of the united
states the vice president
the secretary of defense and the joint
chiefs of staff
i will not authorize funding for
continuation on this documentary
gene abinador
looked devastated the documentary crew
at hbo they
we had a script we'd already had
approval on the script
i have to if i'm going to work on any of
the material that richard dodie has
talked about that they may
be able to unfold
i had to talk with hbo but that's how
in within two weeks
signing a contract
april 9th going to kirtland set up by
peter gersten
and everything goes off on a completely
different track
and then
i had to decide
what am i going to do bridget potter
said if you can
bring back any of those people the
president the vice president
the secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and she seemed to be serious
if you can bring any of them to me
i will then reauthorize going forward on
this documentary
so
the rest of 1980
uh to
in into that period of time 83
uh up to 80
the fall of 85
it was my money
my time
my development
and
[Music]
and then the
the contract ran out
in
1980
end of 1985
and by then i had decided that i was
going to
continue to try to do documentary work
in this field because
those sentences
in that paper
having to do with
these extraterrestrial biological
entities manipulated dna and already
evolving primates to create homo sapien
that
i could never turn away from wanting to
know more
did they use the word biological to
describe the aliens
yes
yes extraterrestrial biological entities
are the three words that make up the
acronym that they have been using for
decades ebens
all caps e b e n little s
ebens extraterrestrial biological
entities
some of the beings are extraterrestrial
biological entities
many more than ebons
are the androids
cyborgs
the robots that are made
today i can tell you that for sure
i know that we're dealing with
tremendous amounts of artificial
intelligence we're also dealing with
holograms but i'm telling you what
happened to your question
in 1983
having signed a contract to do a
documentary for home box office and
exactly what happened
with peter gersten the attorney setting
up the meeting
at kirtland air force base for me to go
with one direction in the film to
ellsworth and
everything
being
everything being focused on this
document
and of course my discussion then was
we're talking about the creation of
of humans by extraterrestrials
do you feel that you were misinformed by
dodie
anybody who is in air force office of
special engagement investigations agent
that is their job
counter intelligence is what they do
so yes or no
brad is giving me a signal that my mic
battery is going to die okay okay
so how about we wrap up with three more
questions does he have a time limit like
on the battery or does he just need to
switch it do you want to take a quick
break linda
do you want to take a bathroom break and
come back
well
i'd have to switch microphones
completely he's got to switch out the
microphones we can do that yeah why
don't we take a two minute break we can
use the washroom he can switch out the
microphones you can have some coffee
you can celebrate your birthday